la cosecha de tomate comienza temprano
por la mañana antes de que haga
demasiado calor y sea demasiado difícil
trabajar esta temporada se han
registrado temperaturas superiores a los
37 grados durante periodos inusualmente
largos
nos tuvimos que regar con mucha más
frecuencia cuando las temperaturas
alcanzaron los picos más altos porque la
planta perdía más agua lo habitual nos
adaptamos acortando los tiempos de riego
a pesar de sus esfuerzos giovanni
terrence yo ha perdido al menos un 20
por ciento de su producción esta es una
situación común para toda la región de
publio esta provincia del sur de italia
suele suministrar casi la mitad de la
producción de tomate del país
este representante del sindicato local
ha venido a evaluar la situación
sólo era cuestión de cultivar la figura
del gato solo solo duda además de la
pérdida de frutos los costos de
producción son mucho más elevados debido
al alza de los precios de la energía
para producir una hectárea de tomates
antes nos gastábamos diez mil euros
ahora nos gastamos 15 mil cultivos 100
hectáreas así que si antes me costaba un
millón de euros ahora tengo que
adelantar 1.5 millones para producir esa
misma cantidad el estado les ha
concedido un crédito fiscal del 20 por
ciento en la compra de combustible una
ayuda insuficiente ya que los costos
adicionales siguen aumentando incluso en
las plantas de procesamiento donde el
precio de una botella de vidrio se ha
duplicado en un año
un kilo de tomates nos cuesta 30
céntimos y pagamos 23 céntimos por el
envase y 5 céntimos por la tapa esto
significa que el producto en sí y su
envase tienen casi el mismo precio lo
cual es absurdo absurdo
los representantes del sector del tomate
han solicitado ayuda urgente al estado
solo en la región de puglia 1500
empresas se encuentran en una situación
peligrosa